allez mon groupe on a un tout nouveau
monde de dragon à découvrir
incroyable
qu'est ce que t'en dis comment on
l'appelle dessous bras qui démangent
vendus je crois tout savoir sur les
draps gauche paris je vous connais vous
nous met une mère n'oublie jamais chaque
dragon a ses secrets
je te les dévoilerai tous tu savais que
tu pouvais faire ça c'est pas mais
maintenant tu sais que tu sers mon sens
du spectacle et aime bien quelque chose
se prépare quelque chose que tu n'as
jamais affronté qu'est-ce qu'il ya
là-dessous
je suis le seul à contrôler les dragon
dragons il faut bon fils complètement
fou je te promets que son poids va
goûter à mon crâne s'ils essayent de
capturer mondragon tabac pour vraiment
je te dise un truc
baroin je sais ce que tu vas dire tu es
aussi magnifique que le jour où j'étais
perdu on lui l'équipement
qu'est ce que tu veux faire dragon vient
pour le dragon on doit l'arrêter
ensemble
t'inquiète mon rang je permettrai pas
que tu arrive quoi que ce soit
tu as le coeur d'un chef
et là d'un dragon mais tu sais que sa
part pas au lavage
les apartés l'un ratonner laisser passer
bonjour la tête
et
sur ces trucs c'est des bébés ils
écoutent personnes
éclater les morgues
oui à tence
occupes l'anfa je te souhaite bon voyage
je